Film Courage: Can we talk about Chekhov’s
gun?
Adam Skelter, author/story artist/screenwriter:
So basically Chekhov’s gun is (the axiom
is) if there’s a gun on the wall, you have
to use it.
If the gun doesn’t go off then you’ve
set up an expectation that you didn’t deliver
on.
And it’s a good principle and again it’s
one of those principles where generally speaking
you want to obey it.
But again look at NO COUNTRY FOR OLD MEN.
Llewellyn Moss is a loaded gun on the wall
and in the end he fails and we don’t get
what we expected but it meant something to
the story.
It’s like every principle, it helps us to
understand that…the general principle is
that if you are going to talk about something,
no detail in any story should ever be wasted.
Especially with screenwriting you want to
be as sparse as possible, you want to be as
specific as possible.
So when you’re writing something it all
has to be…you should regard every single
word as a kind of set-up that you now have
a debt to resolve.
But that said if you are going to break that
rule, have a really good reason for it.
NO COUNTRY FOR OLD MEN is the perfect reason
for it because it directly contributed to
the interpretation of the theme.
Film Courage: So even if you just want to
paint (you know like in novels) will be much
more apt to…an author is going to paint
a world and maybe add little details when
in a screenplay you’re saying don’t do
too much of that world because it’s a waste
of money.
Adam: I would say it even without the writing.
Film Courage: Oh really?
Adam: Because it really comes down to the
voice the language.
And a lot of times when you’re setting something
up, you’re trying to plant seeds of something
up you are planting seeds that you don’t
want the audience to pay attention to because
later it pays off and comes through and you’re
like “Oh, I didn’t even see that coming?”
But if you didn’t set it up beforehand it
feels like a cheat when suddenly introduced.
It really just comes down to really knowing
the craft.
It’s super specific to the needs of your
story and a lot of that will depend on get
it in front of other people, see if it feels
like a cheat, see if it feels like you’re
setting something up.
Sometimes if you say the laser gun sitting
on the table you’re going to be like “The
laser gun?
Are we in the future?”
And those are things you need to pay attention
to and a lot of that is fine tooth combing
your script and getting other people to read
it and gauging their expectations, getting
as much feedback as you can.